c
demain
[Applaudissements]
très heureux d'accueillir
antoine de caunes et à l'école
[Applaudissements]
je vais poser des questions à michel 6
et hakim qui va répondre dans
l'oreillette est ce que vous connaissiez
hakim avant de tourner avec lui oui je
lui ai vendu du site pendant hakim est
pressenti pour la révélation de l'année
aux césar vous pensez qu'il va la voir
je pense qu'il va la voir dans le cul je
pense qu'il va la voir dans le cul il a
un truc à nous dire dans un instant en
toi tu râles jeudi tout le monde croit
que c'est du chocolat c'est pas du
chocolat c'est une vraie un vrai bal et
on va remettre des awards d or du poste
avec antoine de caunes qui laissait
cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
et
ça
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
au choix
je vous
conseil e c
composé sur moi il m'arrive
et faisons entrer les chroniqueurs qui
sont prêts oui oui font grève allez
dites leur qu'ils viennent et on est
pressés d'acheter rapporté un truc des
loges
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
embrasse moi bah c'est bon ouais bah ça
veut bien voilà
[Applaudissements]
pendant des années
vous faites très bien de cheval ouais
c'est fini je sois c'est tout ce que je
faisais à l'époque poneys et bée ware
mes yeux vas-y que l'ennui je peux me
fermais les yeux chez vous et vous aussi
fade castaldi qpr est frais comme je
vais lâcher la formule 1 juste ap je
sais faire aucun animal il part avec la
mobylette électrique terré niel collèges
et lycées bout nous a remerciés
oui je voulais te dire que tu étais une
des personnes que j'aime le plus dans le
monde du show business daily je voulais
dire que tu as toujours été là pour moi
elie quand j'ai eu et nos petits soucis
tout ça le seul qui a pris la parole en
public pour me défendre ces lycées monde
et j'aime ce mec je voulais dire
puisqu'on rien de drôle à dire à savoir
que tu allais je sens que c'est sincère
chez toi franchement ça eh ben tu es
belle [ __ ]
j'ai eu un garçon qui s'appelle damien
mercereau qui journaliste au figaro
aujourd'hui qui me dit cyril j'ai fait
une interview de camille et elle a un
truc en particulier qui la fait sourire
c'est ta gueule je vous dis allez
atteinte d'un cancer de l'estomac
à 8 ans elle récidive dix ans plus tard
peut être 17 ans à 10 ans puis à 17 ans
aujourd'hui son concert s'est généralisé
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu fais demain j'ai rien
de prévu à l'imprévu alors j'ai envie de
faire une surprise parce que je sais que
tu as un rêve ce serait aussi de faire
une émission autour de la table que tpm
paix et bien demain est-ce que tu
acceptes d'être avec nous toutes les
missions et de d'être faire partie des
chroniqueurs de touche par an pose une
erreur tiens une erreur qu'avez-vous
fait un homme au charme à thiais de l'or
noir
[Applaudissements]
je mets 15 po
la 100ème
chemin avec moi
g
soit le patron ce soir c'est milton
michel drucker merci michel que
j'appelle à chaque fois que je dois
prendre une grande décision qui me
conseillent souvent merci mon michel et
c'est toi qui m'avait conseillé de venir
sur direct 8 à l'époque et ouais et je
te remercie encore parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a fait 1
c'est ça c'est pas mal je sais pas de
chez vous mais j'ai kiffé le sont
franchement c'est celle là c'est son
premier album solo on vous le connaissez
bien sûr il faisait partie des one
direction
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on passe au dehors un gars de
l'équipe j'ai nommé fab et jean mi vous
êtes une queen de la chanson est votre
dernier single s'appelle rodéo
[Musique]
les genoux
cinq ans
de solutrans
[Applaudissements]
jobs et va courir ici je vous lis c'est
un énorme carton non kelly tuloup
confirme ses relais dans mes cartons et
des deux vieux schnock à côté de moi je
les balances et il se rappelait pas
d'elle et je l'envié vous êtes vraiment
à l'ouest vous a vraiment des vieux
chemin lac où ils sont semblables sont
fan d'elle même a lancé vous êtes
[Musique]
réponse la réponse est gratuit
bonjour
la bonne réponse est à chabris et déjà
puisque deux singles d'or
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu peux nous faire un petit
discours parce que c'est énorme
qu'est ce que tu as à dire merci
française
manifesto qu'est ce que c'est je vous ai
compris
tout ça fait plaisir